and we're live welcome everybody to
another YouTube hangout I'm super
excited to have a very special guest on
with me
Lois house he runs the school of
greatness it's a podcast it's a book
it's a YouTube channel it's a phenomenon
it's one of the 2.5 youtube entrepreneur
channels that i watch every video of
that comes out and we're here the next
little bit talking about greatness louis
welcome aboard
thanks brother appreciate it man you're
one of the channels that shows up after
every one of my videos because you post
so many great videos of all the great
leaders in the world
anyone that I interview you seem to have
a video with like two million views of
them so I love it we're tackling the
same audience it's perfect sit what are
the other 1.5 shows right so so I watch
yours I have to have a dedicated time
because it because yours are usual about
an hour long and so I don't like getting
interrupted because if I have if it's
hard to catch the flow like if you come
back the next day and you're halfway
through so I gotta make sure I have the
dedicated time the other is Gary
Vaynerchuk actually I learned about you
through Gary you posted a video question
to him in the car one day looks yeah
yeah I thought your book that was coming
out and it's out here it is right here
school of greatness
um and then I started checking out your
channel falling there the other is Chase
Jarvis he's the half he's great
I love chases 30 years of genius that
was fantastic his photography stuff I'm
like I mean and out of I love when you
don't do the business lessons I don't
care so much as a photographer so he's
the half there you go I like it my very
cool I'm glad I made it as a list yeah
you have some amazing content for people
who don't know the backstory don't know
why you're doing all this what like give
us the nothing's with like who you are
but like why did you do this why is it
so important to you what's the genesis
of Lois house starting this business hmm
it all comes back to dreams all comes
back to dreams and as a as a kid I had
big dreams to be a professional athlete
and to you know perform my art in front
of
our G audiences which was sports that
was that was the dream and I always
wanted to be the best that I could be
and be a champion and in sports and then
when that dream ended I played
professional football for a little bit
in America that dream ended from an
injury I was 23 24 years old and
remember just taking you know what's
next you know what's a new dream of mine
what do i what am I supposed to do for
the next you know hopefully 70 plus
years of my life um and what's the
purpose what's the meaning of my life
now since I didn't know what it was
anymore and a couple years in that time
we're sleeping on my sister's couch
she's trying to figure out why what what
am I supposed to do you know who am i
what would I want to represent whatever
going to be doing in the future and
there was a moment when I was 16 years
old that my dad got myself and my mom
two tickets to go watch a live event
that forever changed my life this event
had never been to an event like this
before
never really been to any events before
16 it was in st. Louis Missouri I was
going to a private boarding school then
it was in st. Louis Missouri and it was
like a two day event with Tony Robbins
and it was an event that he had all
these other big speakers come and talk
there was like Super Bowl champions and
Donald Trump was actually there and
Larry King and like all these other
great athletes and coaches things like
that and I remember one point I wasn't
really sure what was happening in this
event it was kind of cool inspiring but
I wasn't really sure until one moment I
was on the floor of this big arena it's
probably 15,000 person arena I was on
the floor if there's a hockey rink I was
in the middle of the hockey rink let's
say and Tony gets off stage he walks
down the aisle and I'm right next to the
ion he walks on the aisle for whatever
reason he stops literally right next to
me he doesn't look at me in the eyes
he's even acknowledged me but he just
stops and stood there and like looked
out into the audience and said something
I don't remember what he said but I
remember the way he made me feel and the
way he moved people
from that experience and his energy was
so passionate that I said that's what I
want to have I want to have that passion
that certainty that clarity that vision
that connection with millions of people
around the world and he was connected to
15,000 people in that moment and many
moments I was like I want to be able to
connect and inspire just like I did with
connecting and inspire people to my art
which was athletics and sports and
little did I know that that would be you
know a 15 years later I would meet him
and interview them and get to tell him
that story and talk about wow you know
my life is transitioned in ways where
I'm you know connecting with millions of
people around the world whether through
my podcast my book online stuff speaking
whatever maybe and I'm trying to inspire
and and perform my art for the world and
along the way I've learned how to
monetize it and build a business and and
help a lot of people along the way and
it's just I'm still figuring it out
you know who knows what's to come in the
future and what may happen but this is
the vision right now and I'm very
excited about it cool so how do you go
from you know you're on the fast track
in the in the athletic career and then
you get the injuria and you and your
sisters couch high didn't decide hey I'm
going to I'm going to do a podcast on
greatnesses or interviewing people like
huh what how did that happen for free
for a few years after playing sports I
had a got on LinkedIn a mentor said to
get on LinkedIn to check it out to see
if there was any job opportunities
because I was looking for like a job or
work or figuring out how was going to
make money after I was done playing
sports and getting injured and I was on
my sister's couch for a couple years in
this transition after sports and so I
started to in long story short make
money teaching people LinkedIn I wrote
books about it I did courses I spoke
about it and then people would said hey
can you teach me Facebook can you teach
me YouTube and you teach me these other
social media platforms that I have no
clue how to use so I started to learn
and master these other social media
platforms and then teach great courses
figure out how can i generate more sales
more leads and just everyday just learn
new skills about online marketing
copywriting branding design
networking building relationships
systems processes whatever maybe
software's on how to generate more sales
for the products in the courses that I
was creating that's for about three and
a half four years what I did and I sold
that off a few years ago because it
really wasn't what I wanted to do I did
want to create social media courses that
wasn't that inspired by it was it moving
me that much it did for a while and then
it kind of had its time in his place and
I told this company my business partner
and I was in like a transition phase I
moved to LA from New York City for a
girl that actually didn't work out what
really bad really sells fast but it was
all great lessons in the end right I'm
grateful for it now and I remember just
kind of being in a funk again I was like
what am i what am i doing what's my
purpose you know I made some good money
but like am I really making an impact
that I want to make in the world is
fulfilling you know I just started
asking these same questions it was like
four years later was a new season of my
life like what I want to do and as I was
driving an allied traffic around here I
was sitting in traffic one day just like
why do I like why don't I have my groove
back you know where was my moxie where's
like my energy like I wasn't my fullest
self and I didn't know how to get it
back and I remember thinking in LA
traffic I was just really angry one day
and sitting there in traffic you know
this came to us like man there's
probably a lot of people that are
miserable sitting in traffic all around
the world that are going from place to
place every single day and are
frustrated they feel like they don't
have the groove back they don't know
their moxie they're not fully fulfilled
doing what they want to do so this was
like a quest it was a journey of like
okay how can I get it back how can I
discover and find it but also serve
other people in the process and at the
time 2012 podcasting was making a
comeback and a couple of friends of mine
were doing it and seeing great results
and so I asked them some questions and
they were like you know it's helping
build my business more than anything
else it's the engagements incredible
like they were telling me all the
benefits of podcasting and I said okay
I think I'm supposed to do this maybe
I'll try this out and see how it does
I'll just try it for a year I'll do it
once a week and but I want to do
something that's not focused on business
solely I don't want to do like a
marketing podcast which everyone's asked
me to do I don't this business
entrepreneur thing like that doesn't
seem exciting to me I was like I want to
do something about that's that's like
about greatness that's about like
principles that they don't teach in
school but is actually the things that
makes people the greatest in the world
of what they do in sports business
philanthropy science whatever may be one
of those intangible things the things
that aren't in books and as a horrible
student in school I hated school but I
loved learning and it was the way which
I learned which was challenging for me
in school which made me hate it but I
love to learn through sports and being
active so I said let's call this the
school of greatness the new type of
school I want to interview people who
were at the top of their game and ask
them to questions about really how they
got there and share that with myself but
also with the world and see what happens
and it just kind of took off man I mean
I had no clue it would take off the way
it did I mean I wanted it to but I had
no clue it would and it's still growing
so I'm just very grateful and blessed
that's a cool story
I'm just rying to think back you know
and there's a lot of people watching now
who and we've called this how to be the
greatest you this session there's a lot
of people who who are frustrated and I
know LA traffic is just insane listen
there's a lot of people who who get
frustrated who then say you know enough
is enough I'm going to do something and
then the next day they wake up and it's
they're like back to their old life like
they had this moment of boldness a
moment of greatness I'm going to fall
back into repeated patterns and habits
and you know life just gets them down
again and they go back to their job or
their regular life like how did you
break that cycle and this is actually
the day I'm gonna go and do something
bigger I think it was just a moment of
like enough was enough like I was
sleeping on my sister's couch for a
couple years originally and she had told
me you know are you gonna start paying
rent in about a year and a half mark
like winning and start paying rent
because I was just eating her food for
free I was like a slob I didn't like
cleanup I was just taking advantage of
the situation and I was 24 years old or
something remember she's been like like
it's time for me to grow up and do
something with my life like I've sat
here for a year and a half was two years
now like depressed miserable whatever I
was doing making excuses like this isn't
who I want to be I aspire to be
something greater you know my parents
didn't raise me to be this way
I wanted to make mine myself proud I
want to make my last name proud I wanted
to make you know my family proud and I
wanted to be a symbol I think you know
I've always wanted to be a symbol of
inspiration of possibilities from my
sports days like I remember the feeling
after the games
when parents or fans or parents of other
players from other teams would come up
to me and say thank you for showing me
what's possible like I had nope you know
there was no way you were able to catch
that ball but somehow you did that it
was like it blew my mind there was no
way you guys should have come back after
how much you were down and what you did
like blew me away
like I loved hearing that and seeing and
other people like this spark of passion
excitement of possibility for what they
could create in their life and right and
I wanted to be that symbol of passion
and vision and focus and commitment
towards my dream to show there was
what's possible and I've never been the
best at anything I'm done you know in
sports I was like always the underdog I
was never the biggest fastest or
strongest dog and I think it's just one
of the show people as possible so that's
what I'm still doing it's like I'm just
a kid from a small town in Delaware Ohio
who had a you know a lot of emotional
turmoil inside growing up and I'm trying
to show people as possible no matter
where you come from do you miss the
football days yeah man I miss it I mean
I was just in Argentina last week plant
I play with the USA handball team for
sport called team handball
and I'm still trying to go after the
Olympics which is a dream of mine and
I'm still trying to show people what's
possible in athletics even at 33 and for
two weeks it was like I was back in my
football days just my teammates don't
really know what I do they're all like
younger they're just athletes so no one
cares about you know my business success
or my podcast or my book it's funny I
was in the airport and like someone
stopped me it was like oh my god I read
your book and I love you the stuff and
my teammates are like wow but you know
it's like but I love just being able to
be an athlete and just focus on
performing and coming together as a team
and and you know trying to win and all
those things it's just it's a great
experience
interesting what was it like since since
Tony had such an impact on you that
first day when you're 16 and then you
you delivered one of the greatest
interviews with Tony I've ever seen like
you're on Tony's private jet and talk
about this book and just an amazing
interview and for those you haven't seen
it you go check it out uh what was that
Ellison are you jealous that I ranks
above yours it's number one on YouTube
it's all love man it's all up to diesel
but I'm just kids like what it's like
this guy had such an impact on you and
here you are now interviewing him you
know he didn't speak right to you when
you were 16 he was next and now it's
like one-on-one attention on his private
jet what was that like for you here's
the thing goes crazy my podcast was only
audio until about a year and a half ago
where I had an opportunity to interview
Tony for the first time and I said wow
I've got this opportunity interview Tony
I've got to bring a film crew like I've
got a videotape this I don't care how
much gonna cost I just got to figure it
out even though I never get a video
interview maybe I did a couple but I
really didn't do any so after that point
I started like doing more and more video
for bigger names that I was bringing on
and then so that first time about a year
and a half ago I was a little nervous
and I spent six weeks researching read
his whole book like I never read books
cover cover I read this whole book which
is like a thousand pages
and you know I just did I watched so
many interviews that he did and so many
TED Talks that he did and all these
other things and to be honest I wasn't
impressed with all the interviews he was
doing like they all said the same thing
he had his talking points he went to
them every time and I was a little like
disappointed that no one really took him
to a different different place
no one got him really to open up and be
vulnerable or just different inside my
vision going into this I was like I'm
committed to getting him off script I'm
committed to being courageous and
sticking with these questions and really
listening and following him and
connected this conversation and the
first time I interviewed him people said
this is the you know I've been following
20 for 20 years I've watched every
interview this was the best one I've
ever seen like never seen him go off
script like this like unbelievable and
so then they then they reached out to me
a year later and said hey can you
interview him again and so this was like
a big deal that they reached out to me
and they were supposed to come here to
my studio and then the day before they
email me and say hey listen we can still
come to your studio but he's got to
leave right afterwards it'd be a big
help if you can come do it like on his
private jet and I was like all right
I'll come do it on his jet but um you
know Dave reached out to me they wanted
me to do it again because they did a
good job before and it got a lot of
sales for him so the second time I felt
even more comfortable me he goes you
know thanks for leaving last time it's
great to see you again we had a little
more connection but it was just um again
another moment to experience and say
thank you for you know that inspiration
16 years ago or whatever was now and
it's really cool got to kind of deepen
the relationship and really learn more
and I felt like that interview was even
better than the one before so cool
you're like a little sidebar part of
what I do with my clips is we we mash up
a little bunch of stuff together in one
of the things that bothers me so much is
is the interviewers often really suck
like after five questions and they want
to get through it and whoever they're
interviewing may drop some crazy
knowledge and then instead of taking
that
the next you know two or three levels
deeper they just ignore it and go on to
the next question
it's like that person just dropped some
gold there man why don't you you know
dive deeper on there and and it's one of
the things that you are really really
great at uh you know I put you to like
it put you in the top ten for sure the
people you know up there with Oprah and
Larry King like all the guys who ask the
questions like you really care and like
the one that really hit me hardest was
um Chris Guillebeau who had had a new
book coming out and he was on your show
he came to my studio in Toronto and I
was researching just like you know
research me and like hey what do people
ask them and he spent an hour with you
and it was totally different than every
other interview and you got him to talk
about his brother committing suicide and
jail and he called it a therapy session
I'm just totally off script and and yeah
just amazing and one of the reasons why
you're part of the two-and-a-half that
Club or what I on every week every day
um one of your brother you want a secret
to getting people to open up yeah here's
here's the Golden Nugget it's a I mean a
lot of it is being present and listening
but it starts before the interview start
the forming interview in your
preparation and in a question you ask
the person that you're about to
interview where you want so every court
every time I do something to ask them
all the same question
do I have permission you know to get to
make this the best interview possible
and if they say yes I say okay well do I
have permission then to take it anywhere
everywhere I need to go great or is
there anything off limits that we cannot
talk about and I think in that
positioning you know Chris said in that
moment he said we can talk about
anything I just don't talk about my
marriage or my brother's death I said
okay I just want to let you know and I'm
completely cool to respect that we don't
have to read on to but I just want to
let you know that I
guarantee you if we do talk about those
things or some of those things that this
will probably more impactful than if we
don't so if your goal is to make this
the best possible we can make it and
more impactful and you know get this
message out there and sell more books
then I think we should go there and so
he said you know what let me get right
okay so I think it's it's setting up
it's the staging beforehand to really
let people know hey we're going to go
there and get ready and you gave me
permission to ask whatever I want
remember this so I'm going to go there
right and that's what a lot of people
miss out on like really setting people
up and preparing them I think - what
comes across in your content is that you
actually care about the questions like
care about the answer you care about
taking to the next up not just about hey
how can I make great video or great
audio like I Lewis house actually care
about you as a human being and what
you're seeing might impact me and it's
just out of genuine curiosity and
interest where most people are asking
together just you have your questions
and that's it you're popping at it it
all starts with me out of curiosity and
I think if I'm not interested and
excited about it then other people are
going to notice that and they're not
going to share it so cool well let's
talk about the book I got it here you've
got in your background I know it's you
always have a great product placement
you put it like let's see put it right
there I will pop it right there there
you go why the book what's in the book
how can people learn to be great you
know yeah you know as I was doing school
greatest podcast for the first couple
years I did it once a year or once a
week for the first year and people said
we want more I listen to you every
Monday and then I have to go listen to
some other crappy podcast the rest every
other day and so I started doing two
weeks a second year then at the end of
the second year they said I listed you
every Monday Tuesday that I've to list
everyone else the rest to me can I can't
wait so I said okay this is a lot of
work people I'll do three times a week
but it's a lot of work I don't like any
more than that but I've been doing that
and people just kept saying we want more
like we love these interviews we love
the information we're getting but can
you break it
down can you like package it together
and give us more like steps and things
like that so essentially I created a an
online program called the school games
Academy which is like my trial was my
trial like online program for the
podcast and I started to design a
curriculum around what I learned from
the podcast but also my sports
background and just getting results in
life and as I was doing this I noticed
like some credible results for people
and they just wanted more so I said you
know what some people can't afford this
five under our program one of the
package it and put it into a book really
share my story get some great examples
from people have been on and then give
it exercises and details of how I've you
know created the results in my life in
sports at the top level in you know to
sports and that will actually you know
is world class in to sports football and
decathlon in college and then
professional football and then us a
handball played against Olympians so how
did I achieve those results of sports
how to achieve it in business in a quick
time relationships and all these things
how did I generate those things from the
beginning to the end
and then how is everyone else generating
incredible results that I've interviewed
so I decided to package together and
found that there were comm eight common
themes of how to achieve greatness in
your life in any area of your life
there's eight common principles that all
these guests had in common and I
reverse-engineer them just made it as
simple as possible for me I mean things
to be so simple that I could understand
them that's why I package the way I do
because I could never understand from
books growing up and that's what it is
so it's about how to be great in your
life in any area and there's eight key
principles and exercise at the end of
each chapter to help you follow through
it on those principles sure and each
chapter is its own principle basically
exact and it's easy to we didn't go
through for people watching and trying
to make a change in their life can you
give like a quick high level what the
eight points are um today you know I'll
give you the I'll give you the top to my
opinion that are I'll give you three how
about that the
first one is to create a vision you know
the greatest leaders everyone that you
posted on your YouTube channel all the
greatest leader Steve Jobs Tony Robbins
Oprah they all have a very clear vision
of what they want the people that aren't
generating results don't have that
vision it's hard to generate incredible
results with a vision without a vision
so that's number one
it's create a vision that inspires you
and inspires other people the second
thing the second principle is with a big
vision in any big dream comes huge
obstacles it's just going to happen
want to walk it's a big dream to get a
walk when you don't know how to walk so
you're going to fall over and over and
over for the first year and a half and
take you finally figure it out right out
of talk and you don't have to talk
because you don't understand you master
the skill so you're just going to blur
out but I thought ah until you
understand and figure it out
there's going to be a challenge every
step of the way to achieve any vision as
being an being so the greatest leaders
in the world learned how to turn any
adversity into their advantage they use
it as a strength they embrace it it's
like Batman you know he was afraid of
the bat so he said screw it I'm gonna
become a bat and embrace the bat essence
and do everything that a bad just so I
don't have this fear in my life anymore
so you turn the adversity into your
advantage then you develop a champions
mindset okay no more than three they
develop a champions mindset and this is
really the principle that is is just
huge because we don't believe in
ourselves we don't have the confidence
and the belief that we can create the
vision we want there's no chance it's
going to happen either so we've got to
develop this confidence this mindset of
a champion and break down what that is
and how to develop it a part was
actually going to call this next
principle is developing hustle and this
is actually going to be the title the
book was going to be hustle because
essentially everything I've done up into
this point has been based on hustle and
just wanting it bad enough
and diving for the loose balls in life
and doing whatever it takes and my agent
said I won't publish a book that has the
word hustle on the cover as the title
Wow
but that was like I was like this is the
book though this is the essence it's
hostile this is what it is and he goes I
just
he's like old school and it's just like
no I won't publish that it's got a bad
kind of Tatian that word but a lot it's
like I understand okay fine I'm actually
glad it's school greatest now not
impossible and it's funny my publisher
is publishing a book called hustle here
in the next few months which so those
the first four hustle is you know diving
for the loose balls of life there's so
many people that are analytical so many
people that are paralyzed by options and
analyze everything it's got to be
perfect and right really just gotta be
willing to put yourself out there and
hustle those are the first that's the
first half of the book I'll finish with
the last principle and that is to live a
life of service I think vision having a
very clear vision and living a life of
service are two things that all great
leaders the most inspiring great leaders
I would say and it notice matters we
create results for ourselves and none of
it matters if we're not living to serve
other people as well we were born or
whatever reason we were born whatever
you want to believe in we were born
we're here we have this incredible world
as our playground that was given to us
it was just for whatever reason it's
here for us to experience explore all
the people in the world are here and I
think it's our duty to give back to the
people that are here into the world that
was here before us I love that mindset I
you know totally on board with it I'm
wondering how do you how do you go from
the guy who's broke on the couch not
paying rent to now believing that he can
make a contribution and believing that
it's important to go out and make the
world a better place and give back to
the people around that just a switch or
just as you hung around these people
it grew within you and realize that this
thing that didn't exist I how did that
come about I think of a number
since I learned going up in sports you
know playing on a team you you learn to
sacrifice for the team you learn to give
and work your butt off to give to the
rest of your teammates because they get
to you when I was five through 12 my dad
every year we had a foreign exchange in
from another country stay with us for
six months and you know he paid for that
individual can he get paid for this he
paid for the food their clothes you know
travel whatever it was because he wanted
to give back
and he knew the importance of giving
back to the community to the exchange
students that came to our community he
gave back so I witnessed that my dad
always had us too you know community
service he was always giving and I think
it's really hard to be depressed and
giving at the same time when we are like
in a bad mood but we just go and give to
other people and make someone else's day
like it's hard to stay depressed or
angry or frustrated when you're in a
giving mindset so when we come from a
place of contribution service giving
it's actually the most rewarding
feelings it's actually like the best
feeling in the world when you give to
someone so I just started saying okay
how can I give more because I was in
this funk I was like how can I get out
of myself and give more when I did that
I was like man this feels really good
it's almost like the most selfish thing
you can do is give to other people
because it's the best feeling the world
so just give a keep giving when you feel
angry or upset or ungrateful or
frustrated just like go give and it's
going to shift everything around for you
I love it well people are loving what
you're saying the chat is blowing up I
want to get to a couple questions from
from the live chat but first one for me
selfishly um
just about the book so I have a I have
my first book coming out in December and
I'm curious as to what was the biggest
thing that helped you when you were
launching you I know you tried a whole
bunch of different things I had your
major hustle on a little big well what
was like the one or two things that
really helped move the needle for you
when launching a book so you know advice
for a first-time author to get some
greatness that mm
I would take a game plan of the 50
biggest influencers you know who have
you know really targeted audiences
around your topic and figure out a way
to get on their YouTube show their
podcast do a guest post for them
whatever may be and find those top 50
that are like if you could get on these
top 50 shows or blogs it would be like a
game-changer focus on those 50 first I
would say don't say yes to everything
like when I did it I was like I want to
try everything because I'm just going
for it and I said yes so many interviews
that had like a couple thousand
followers or whatever that just wasted
hours and hours and hours of my time
that I wish I would just put into like
the top 50 I create a list of 50 names
that are like wow if I got on all these
they would be the game changer and then
figure out every way possible to get on
those that'd be the first thing the
podcast tour for me sold a ton of books
so you know whether that's YouTube or
podcasts I think that's the same thing
and the blog and then the big thing for
me was bulk orders like for getting
forgetting the New York Times let's like
getting a lot of bulk holders up front
from people figuring out partnerships
and deals to do that I would say those
are the top things and then one more
would be doing a bonus page so you know
for a hundred books you'll get this a
thousand books 10 bucks 20 bucks because
if someone's going to buy one book
they'll buy - if someone's going to buy
five the by 10 so incentivize people to
buy more to give away and show them the
the meaning of buying a few more books
and what to do when they give it away to
other friends so um
that's what I look for cool I love it I
asked Luis to one or two things it gives
me three you know providing that extra
value I don't know man hey I'm back up
next year too so that's why I continue
that value well I love it um okay well
let's get some questions so Rishi is
asking
Luis if you had to simplify tapping into
your personal greatness with one single
action what would that action be thank
you so much one single action the
my greatness Oh little action are they
going to be serviced I mean just giving
I was like I like it I like it um Luke
is asking how to start a business with
little or no money I mean you did it so
advice um I mean it's hard to give a
simple answer this find a way to sell
something create something that you can
generate a sale from whether it be a
service or a product and then sell that
as much as you can I mean it's hard to
give an answer to this unless you really
and let's have more context but you need
to generate sales you don't have a
business unless you generate sales so
you need to have something that people
want that you can sell to over and over
and over again that's how you started Oh
Louis so far everyone you've interviewed
who has had the greatest lasting impact
on you and why it's lasting in fact I
mean Tony Robbins was great obviously it
was probably my favorite but I've got a
wall of greatness over here I'll show
you some of the people I've had on it's
like a little greatness on is behind the
scenes
yeah behind the scenes so um I would say
you know I really liked there so many
it's pretty tough I really liked Rob
Bell he kind of came on at a time when I
was when I really enjoyed like his
information is conversation about
spirituality and things like that I'm on
a couple times so I would say one with
Rob Bell well Anna's more set was
actually really powerful when they had
on median yeah Canadian there huh
everyone is so amazing to me that's why
I have them on I have them on for a
reason because I'm excited about it so
how many people have you had on I don't
know I'm at 300 and something 330
something episodes I've probably had but
some a lot of those are five-minute
Fridays and solar rounds by me so I'd
say at least 150
I think and how do you go about picking
them because they seem to be I mean the
Univ is always great but some of the
people I recognized yeah well those
entrepreneurs or actors or whatever a
lot of people no idea who they are and
it's like wow I didn't know they did all
this stuff how do you you know the
person from the matrix I forget her name
Kurian daryl should you try it on I'm
like wow carrie-anne moss haven't heard
that name for a long time and it just
seems so random but then she had such
great such a great story such greens
that I usually yeah so like how do you
pick is it just its sequel you're
interested by or what it's people that
inspire me man it's people that I'm
interested by some of these people take
you know years to get them on sometimes
I get pitched an idea by a publicist or
whatever and I'm like yeah I really like
this topic of this idea I get pitched
every day though so I'm saying no
constantly but sure a lot of is just
reaching out and asking for
introductions for friends that I know
who know these people and making it
happen
sure well I assume like if they have a
book or something to promote you know
Luis is on the tour what a must-have
stop on the tour to get the name out but
I'm wanting to the people that it goes
might be the easy ones that come in to
you now but there's people is there
anyone on your list now like I really
want to get to him or her oh yeah I mean
they're still still not easy I mean a
lot of people don't even know podcasts
are so I want I really want Will Smith I
want Jim Carey um I know you put both of
those on your show for your stuff um who
else - I want the rock really bad man I
want the rock so if you can make those
happen let me know you never know the
intention is out there now everybody
watch YouTube
I love it um supreme team can you
recommend us five books besides your own
uh the must-have book is The Alchemist
The Alchemist everyone should read um I
would say I'm looking at my wall books
right now I really like influence by
Robert child Beauty
who the champions mind is a good one I
really like the champions mind it's like
a sports psychology book but it's kind
of developing that champions mindset
just by Jim aphromoo um I'm worth taking
up here
I think awaken the giant within Tony
Robbins book is great I think yeah and
number five I would say for the men
watching the way of the superior man and
for the women watching if the Buddha
dated Wow I haven't heard of either of
those two powerful books cool um this is
a specific one but I think you'll you'll
know what James is asking Louis I listen
to your power of clarity episode every
day and I've instituted what you say to
do in that episode and I'm seeing my
channel grow anything you can add to
those five steps if you remember well
let me refer oh we just see really quick
if I have it down I've steps achieve any
goal of clarity you guys super fan and
James here this has 77 comets this post
let me just look at this really quickly
one point 1,000 shares alright we see
you know this did really well um you
listen to it every day man every day
this is an older episode - how do we
know what they are um ask him to post
down the kind of what the five things
are and I'll add to it if he follows up
okay James there's your challenge well
what would the 2016 Redux virginity goal
of our like clarity clarity and
achieving goal that would Lewis how to
say in 2016 um what I would say is
it all comes down to what symbol you
want to represent hmm comes down to the
symbol you want to represent I wanna do
an episode on this soon about what's
your symbol maybe I'll even write a book
about this I think we should think about
you know we all have symbols that were
putting out every single day a lot of
people put out you know frustration
anger confused distracted overwhelmed
stressed they put up this symbol
stressed every day they're just a symbol
of stress when you think of that person
you think man they're always stressed or
there's some people that you think about
them man he's just so Cleary so she's so
honest she's so positive she's so joyful
she's so passionate like that's a symbol
that they have as well so I think it
comes down to what symbol do you want to
be in the world do you want to become
the Batman symbol which is symbol
symbolizes something you want to become
a symbol of joy of peace of giving of
service like what is your symbol and
figure that out first and then every day
you should be focusing on being that
symbol that's a good step to getting
clear I think what's the symbol huh
what I want to symbolize as my legacy
when people say my name and think about
my name what symbol is attached to that
do you think like what's a word that
comes to mind when it when I think of
Luud house you know they think of
greatness yeah it could be that I mean I
don't even know if that's like my war
that I want to be symbolized as not
necessarily even though I kind of like
attachment stuff to that word but it's
more it could be multiple symbols you
know I want to be known as a guy that
like won for his dreams like makes
anything happen that creates abundance
wherever he goes that generates wealth
and everyone that comes around him that
is like so passionate and joyful in um
always chases his dreams like these are
the symbols that I want to represent
that is just inspiring to be around like
I just want to hang out with the guy you
know whatever it is
just want to have that symbol so I think
that's that's what we need to think
about okay what do we want other people
to really think about us and how can we
show up that way every single day I love
it so so is this gonna be a Lewis Howes
monologue rant video might be yeah it
might be it might be a podcast yeah come
on yourselves you gotta put on the
YouTube channel too man right out right
we all want to see it all right we'll
see grant on simples I love it perfect
I'm Vinay's asking who should read the
school of greatness we should read the
school grayness um that's a great
question anyone who wants to get to the
next level in their life their business
their relationships or their
spirituality if you feel like you've
achieved something great already but you
haven't figured out how to get to that
next vision this is going to guide you
if you feel like you're completely stuck
and have no clue what the next step is
this is going to guide you so any one of
those positions it's great for both cool
bf Williams jr. if you had to live your
playing days over again what would you
do differently knowing what you know now
to be more impactful both on and off the
field oh man
you know it's interesting you know I
always had a dream of like going played
Ohio State like every year in college I
thought it was that's transfer to go
play because I was like a big dream of
mine but the funny thing is like I
wouldn't have been a two-sport
all-american I wanted to broke the sport
record I want to have gotten injured and
like had this path that I'm on now so I
probably like who know I'm being jail or
something so I don't know if I would
change anything in terms of what I did I
think maybe my energy would've been
different I think that was a pretty like
sore loser like I hated to lose because
for me in life everything was if you
know it was all win lose there was no
win win there's no win win situation was
all if you lose you're a loser if you
win you're a winner
and I never wanted to feel like a loser
so I had to make every situation an
opportunity from
Winn I think I just wasn't that good at
a lower you know where now I've learned
a lot more you know we we just played a
bunch of games and Argentina against
Olympic teams and teams better than us
we lost a bunch we only want two out of
seven and it was very frustrating like I
still hate losing right I'm a very
competitive American right this is who a
lot of us are and I hate it but I've
learned to just be like okay where the
lessons been learn to really say you
know what that's in the past there's
nothing I could do we just lost there's
nothing I can change so let me move
forward and focus on the next moment um
I think I would like days after a loss
it would like suffocate me and paralyze
me and I would just be the nasty mood
and this and that and I think I would
have shifted that you know if I could
have because it wasn't helping me or
anyone around me interesting I just saw
a clip from Mike Tyson recently or
recycled the secret to life is losing
and it's like a double tape a secret to
life is losing I'd like to interview him
actually I think it'd be a great
interview he's doing a lot more stuff
yes I don't think you need one Gregory
the undisputed truth is pretty cool
have you seen it now it's his he's a
one-man Broadway show called the
undisputed truth and he's actually
really funny and a great performer so I
got to figure out who his publicist is
if you can know anyone who knows his
publicist let me know I'll reach out to
cool I'll look into it I might yeah
we'll see
um violet is asking are you happy and
what makes you happy
yeah I'm happy I think what makes me
happy is growth and contribution and so
for there are moments where I'm
frustrated and pissed off and you know I
just may be unhappy but I think overall
as long as I'm growing and contributing
to people that I'm happy um and again
it's not perfect roses every single
moment of every single day and I think
that if it was always happy and perfect
that I wouldn't be happy either so
but I think if long as 90% of time I'm
feeling happy then that's pretty good
what how do you make sure that that's
consistent right I mean so you're
interviewing three people a week I'm
sure you get a lot of that you feel like
you're growing and learning by having
those conversations but the down days in
between like I got four other days
during the week you're not interviewing
somebody you might just be doing the
grunt work of running a business how do
you set yourself up for growth on a
daily basis so that you are happy I mean
I you know the interviews aren't all in
one day sometimes it's two in one day
sometimes it's one every day to get
ahead you know it all depends but it
would be even interviewing people can be
exhausting you know if I do two
interviews in a day back-to-back it's
exhausting like because I'm so present
and so focused and all my energy and
attention of that hour-and-a-half to be
with that person be prepared if you do a
couple of those then I've got a hundred
emails and I've got my whole team that
needs things from me like it can be a
lot of energy in a day so I manage it
from making sure I take care of myself
every day and by working out by eating
good foods by meditating by taking time
for me I think if I give all my time to
everyone else that I'm going to be
unhappy but it's I've learned to really
make sure take time for me in the
morning or at night that's just like my
time and that's just personally what I
need some people maybe don't need that
but I need a couple hours to just goof
off or play or go outside do whatever
and that housing balance it you
mentioned meditating and and something
I'm glad you brought it up because I
actually started using the mind space
app our headspace headspace after your
iman and I do the same my wife and I the
same thing as you or like at night now
to fall asleep we do our 10 minute
session and that way and then pass out
so Lewis house changing lives in more
ways than one I love it it's cool and
that was another great interview you did
with him that was awesome um I want to
be conscious at the time and I wanted to
flip the script on you so for those of
you who aren't super familiar with Lucis
Channel Heat
ends his interviews the same way pretty
much every single time we saw the ones
I've seen with like three common exits
and so I thought you know what let's
give it to Louis since he's over here he
starts up with the three truce and the
three truce and he knows what's coming
so he has a little bit of time to think
about the three truths our imagine
everything you've created right like
this book doesn't exist and his youtube
channel podcasts are gone and he's about
to die and he has to write three think
piece of paper that he will be his his
symbol is like a sea you know the people
remember him by the things that he knows
to be true forever that he wants people
to share I gave you some time to think
about it Lou as well pumping it up there
so what are the three truths that you
want people to know well do you like
that question to ask do you like this
question like it I'm always curious it
teaches you how self-aware some people
are when I just thing they know it and
others really struggle with thinking
about what they're gonna say you know
all these questions I ask to never think
about myself I've said this a couple
times though because people ask me for
me let me think the first thing is three
truths that come from love in every
situation and you'll always win the
second thing is your dreams are the most
important thing in the world so make
sure you follow them and the third thing
is to live fully in service I think
those are good 3 truth I love it it's
good it's good ok so that's the first
tradition the 3 truths the second thing
is I something I love that I haven't
seen any other interviewer do he
acknowledges every guess that he has on
to like something deeply meaningful to
him
uh and so Lewis I want to acknowledge
you for the awesome interviews that you
do and the consistent content and just
you know from an entrepreneurial world
and what sort of entrepreneurial content
but it really serves and inspires a lot
of people I'm sure you get the comments
you
get two emails everyday but it really
has an impact you look at James is
watching every single day you know I
look forward to the next thing of you
you're going to do I make time an hour
to like chunk out to make sure I can
watch Louis's contents we just wanted to
acknowledge you and thank you for the
great impact that you're having on
people's lives thanks Evan appreciate
that man talk to me and then the last
thing that he always does is he asks his
guests you know it's coming yes guess
what is your definition of greatness
right school of greatness so he asked
everybody you're definitely now I know
you've answered this before but dissing
with that tradition what is your
definition of greatness
you know this definition changes for
people sometimes so the reason I ask is
we all have a different definition and
you know in high school it was different
than it is now for me right so my
definition right now greatness is
discovering and pursuing your dreams
while making a full-time income to
support yourself and impacting impacting
the maximum number people in the world
in pursuit of that dream I love it I
also love how you're open to changing
the definition over time and not being
boxed into like this is what I said two
years ago so I got to keep with that
even though I mean I represent what
you're thinking anymore it's cool it
takes courage to do it yeah you may not
realize it but like a lot of people do
get stuck and those those chains of
habit so no we're different people that
we were a day before when ten years ago
you know yeah
in high school it was greatnesses making
a lot of money and you know having a
girlfriend I don't know like it was
different than her being an athlete and
being an all-american it was like a
different vibe energy so I think it
depends on what the season of our life
love it Lewis thank you so much for
joining guys I've linked up his website
in description below go check him out
check out the YouTube channel go buy
school of greatness really appreciate
the time thank you guys all for watching
as well continue to believe and we'll
see you soon thanks Evan